on retrouve billy walsh le président de
l'association des sociétés de
développement commercial de montréal
consomme sur orge
lyon est ce que est ce que c'est un
soulagement aujourd'hui pour les
commerces à faire c'est là la nouvelle
qu'on attendait depuis environ deux mois
au moins
oui je pense que c'est un soulagement
mais je vous dirais que d'un autre côté
autant que celui des commerçants le
travail commence et il n'y est loin
d'être terminée
oui c'est ça ce n'est que ce n'est que
le début maintenant il faut il faut que
les gens aient confiance de revenir
comment comment on va faire au cours des
prochains mois pour ramener la confiance
des gens et ramener des gens parce qu'il
aura pas beaucoup de touristes y aura
pas de festival pas d'étudiants peu de
travailleurs aussi premièrement je pense
que le commerce ont un rôle à jouer qui
est excessivement important ce sont les
hommes c'est que la clientèle de se
déplacer dans des endroits qui sont
prévisibles et qui seront sécuritaires
donc l'ensemble des mesures de santé
publique doivent être respectés quand on
parle de marque plexiglas de jeunes
sanitaires ainsi que de distanciation
sociale ce sont leurs quatre mesures qui
doivent être respectées à la lettre par
l'ensemble des commerçants
je vous dirai pour être en mesure de
sécuriser leurs corps présente le lit
est aussi la cliente
dans un deuxième temps un espace public
particulièrement en ville ou dans la rue
dans les zones plus denses du québec à
montréal en particulier doivent être
aménagés pour être en mesure de donner
de l'aide quand on veut pas
nécessairement être confiné en fait une
clientèle dans les espaces d'espoir donc
comment on va réaménager l'espace où les
corps faire en sorte que ceux-ci se
sentent à l'aise de venir magasiner sur
les lanternes sur leurs affaires et
qu'elle puisse soutenir le commerce
local
maintenant c'est sûr et certain que ces
initiatives love vont devoir être
accompagnée de campagnes de
communication excessivement importante
bon justement favoriser l'achat local et
faire en sorte que les citoyens
clientèle tu es sakho rendez vous ils
soutiennent visiblement le commerce de
quartier
je présume que la plupart la très grande
majorité des commerçants étaient prêts à
cela
aujourd'hui ça fait quand même plusieurs
semaines donc on avait reporté la
réouverture mais est-ce qu'ils sont
armés financièrement pour vivre une
période qui va être une période de
transition là il peau claire comprend
pas les activités commerciales normales
note l'ex en question effectivement
certains ont pu réouvrir mais toujours
en ayant pour certains autres le spect
je vous dirais d'aller qualité parce
qu'on se cachera pas ça fait trois ans
moi de fixer les frais d'opération que
l'on maxime sans nécessairement avant de
revenus donc c'est une bonne nouvelle on
pourrait ouvrir les commerces mais les
trois prochains mois les quatre
prochains mois d'été vont être effacées
déterminant je pense pour donner le ton
pendant l'année quand vous le mentionnez
dans le reportage le sida touristes
travailleurs
on va devoir être en mesure de
réinventer le modèle très créatif de
aussi agir au niveau des frais
d'opération pour arriver à ces trois
quatre prochains mois à sortir une marge
de profit est intéressante pour nous
permet aussi de se lancer dans le
business et celui d'octobre novembre
décembre l'équipe on vous présentera
plusieurs questions je voudrais par
rapport à l'achalandage par rapport aux
mesures de francisation social c'est sûr
et certain que sur des artères
commerciales
ce qu'on peut penser que les gens feront
le film pour apprendre à l'extérieur en
période hivernale
donc c'est des questions qui nous
concernent beaucoup présentement et on
va devoir trouver des solutions
collectives avec les paliers
gouvernementaux ne pourrait pas en
mesure d'arriver à une piste de solution
est ce que vous vous attendez à ce que
beaucoup de détaillants ne passe pas à
travers on se cale beaucoup sur les
chiffres disent ils en feront l'annoncé
en iran quand % des commerces qui
pourrait être laissé en arrière parce
qu'ils là et c'est sûr et certain que au
niveau de la restauration des bars
dépendamment de la réouverture ça va on
m'annonce et selon ses mots de joueurs
mairie fermée quand on considère que ce
sont des affaires commerciales de
montréal de façon un peu général on a
environ 30% des commerces de
restauration et bar des genres on est
avec 1 15% de vacances
on avait déjà avant la crise puisqu'à la
question du commerce était reconnaissant
après rose avant la crise on se rappelle
que la ville de montréal a déposé avait
ouvert une commission sur les locaux
vacants
parce que certains affaire commerciale
affichant un taux de 10 à 12% donc déjà
dans cette situation là on est rendu
environ à 25 ans c'est un problème qui
est majeure c'est un problème qu'on va
devoir c'est dangereux qu'on va l'avoir
vraiment prendre à bras le corps parce
que c'est toute la question de
l'animation de la vitalité de l'identité
de la fraction donc article l'attraction
david à montréal au grand complet un
dernier mot sur le télétravail très
valorisé en ce moment certains parlent
de révolution du télétravail qui serait
quelles seront les conséquences pour les
commerces au centre ville et dans les
quartiers que de voir de plus en plus de
gens être en télétravail
ben en fait parfois le malheur des uns
fait le bonheur des autres je m'explique
dans les grandes artères commerciales ou
dans les grands pôles d'employabilité
auquel on venait joindre une fonction
commerciale texan à saint-laurent vieux
montréal
c'est sûr et certain qu'à l'apport de
cette clientèle là aujourd'hui el bourak
marquant donc comment on va être
capables de la combler ou comment le
modèle d'affaires des commerçants dont
elle est capable
des commerçants et des propriétaires
aussi évidemment mais comment celui-ci
doit être capable de s'ajuster à cette
clientèle d'hommes encore en
contrepartie dans les quartiers
périphériques donc deux premières
couronnes au centre de montréal c'est
sûr et certain que s'il n'y a plus de
travail dans des quartiers où les gens
étaient habitués de quitter pour être en
mesure de détailler dando pour l'emploi
on va se retrouver là avec une clientèle
captive qui pourrait éventuellement
bonne idée de l'heure du lunch ou encore
la fin de journée pour transférer ses
emplettes de leur ancien pôle
d'employabilité vers le nouveau qui est
celui de la résidence et ce don pour
peut-être que ça pouvait s'avérer être
un avantage ou du moins une clientèle
supplémentaire pour ces affrontements
ainsi qu'à monsieur walsh merci pour cet
entretien ce soir merci à vous acheter
local